では 質問とか聞きたい他のことでもあったら
確かめてください はい
先ほど人間は自分が見せたいと思っている顔と
その反対の顔と二つを持っているっていうことをおっしゃられたので
それでちょっと自分で思ったことは
そうすると自分が自分はこういう人間だっていう風に
なんとなくこう考えていること
自分の性格についてとかあるわけですけれども
それもやっぱり自分が思い込みたい自分で
また本当の自分っていうのは
ちょっと言い方が難しいですけど
本当の自分というのは自分が思っている自分とはむしろ反対くらいなんじゃないかって思った方がいいでしょうか
それもまた まあ頭で考えたことかもしれないんですけども
うん 人に何か喋っている人に見せる顔っていうのは
またそちらの正反対 その裏であって
一人で私はこういう人間だなと自分一人で思う時でも
また裏の顔があってね
だからいつでもそういう風になってなって
だったら一体全体本当に自分何やってるの？ね
結局それ認めたくないんで
だからそうなるんですよ
本当の自分というのはだらしなくて無知で
もう感情の奴隷で 怠けで
極端に 極端に自我しか知らなくて
自分というその認識以外何一つも知りたくないという
もうもう狂いももういいところです
でもその極端くらいものでは何一つ得られないということを知っているんです
だから演技 演技 演技 演技
演技で 演じる演じる分はそれなりに自分の自我がなんとか保たれます
本当は勉強したくないんだけど
勉強して合格したらよかった俺はという感じになるだけ
それで俺が俺に栄養が入るんです
全てそういうもので 自我を自我に刺激栄養を与えるためにやっているんです
しかし 自我そこがもう怠けで
もう自分以外何も知りたくはないのが本当の自分なんです
それは誰も認めてないんです
だからみんな演じるんです
あのヴィパッサナー瞑想している時に
自分が感じたことについて
自分はこういうどこかでこうラベリングしながらも
自分はこういう人間だから
こういう感じ方をするとかっていう風に思っちゃったりとかすることもあるんですけれども
例えば胸の辺りが苦しいとか
体のこわばりなんか 自分は怒りっぽい人間だから
こういう風に体がこわばるんじゃないかとかということも考えてたりもしたんですけれども
それももう全く意味がないというか
全く意味がないんです
それまた自我に栄養を与えるだけ
ヴィパッサナーやってるつもりでも
その自我の方に自分が栄養を与えているだけになってしまうということですか
考えちゃうとそうなるんです
先ほどの先生マーラの話なんですけれども
人間が悟るのがマーラが嫌がるっていうことは
マーラにとって人が悟らないことは利益があるんでしょうか
それとも人間の渇愛っていうのがマーラにとって
当然人間の渇愛 人間の心そのものをマーラにしていますけどね
修行する場合はね でも世間は悟らせてくれないでしょう
世間は悟らない方向を応援しているでしょう
若い子は例えば瞑想したいし
例えば全て俗世間捨てたいと言うと
親が何言ってもお前はもう元気だから勉強してね
結婚して子供作ってちょうだいと
まだまだ子供でしょうと
世界知らんでしょうと言うんです
世間のこと知ってからやればいいんじゃないかとかね
そういう風に反対の方向へ進むんですよ
マーラのことっていうのはまああんまりわからないんですね
かなり  まあ邪魔で悟ることだけは
それだけはやめてちょうだいという態度でいる神みたいです
他は修行は大丈夫です
修行をしたり 良いことをしたりとかね
それは彼があまり応援もしないし
邪魔もしない うん 徳を積むこともやめちゃってヴィパッサナーに入ると
これはおかしいということになっちゃうんです
何するのかと 何かあるでしょうね
マーラに対しては何か嫌なことね
あると思います でなきゃ邪魔する必要ないでしょうと
だから神話的に言えるのは
もう彼が一切の生命より上で
彼の力で誰でもビビるというふうな
ものすごい力を持っているんだと
その次元の生命は だから自分のことをヘイトも持たない存在いると
これがね 政治的に考えて
だから独裁政権が現れると
ちょこっと悪口言っただけでもそいつを殺すでしょ
意味がないでしょうに
例えば昔映画で見たことなんですけど
この あのドイツの戦争に関わる映画で
なんか名前は分かりませんだけど
まあもうヒットラー神様のように
学校でもどこでもずっと教えてあって
どちらでも写真貼って
それに礼をさせてヘイルヒットラーとか言わせたりとかね
あれで子供たちも ある子供たちがふざけて
なんかヒットラーの写真があって
これで髭描くんですね
そんなことはやる事だからね
そこは事故よ しちゃって
これで誰かに見つけて
それであの軍人がいたんだからね
なんとかの名前のね その連中が来てクラスに会って
誰ですかと これ書いたのはと
で 調べて調べて もうみんな怯えちゃって
とにかくそこもう書いた子を
子供たちだからいくらなんでもそれ隠せませんだからね
こいつやとか何とか言っちゃうしね
それお前がかと言ったら
出て出てこい それ捕まってもうて殺しちゃうんですね
それは映画なんですけど
実際どうか分かりませんだけど
やっぱりこれ独裁政権
子供が髭に顔に髭描いたんだからって
独裁者の権力には何のこともないでしょうに
自分が軍隊を牛耳っているんだから
それでもやっちゃうんでしょ
北朝鮮で金正日に何か悪口言ったことと同じですよ
どこかで壁にでもね もう
もうなんとか様がね もう死んでしまえとでも書いちゃうと
あの四方の色人々みんな調べるでしょう
書いた人を見つけたらもう首が飛んじゃうんです
何でですかね そんなの
そこまでやる必要あるんですかね
国民は旺盛に立ち上がってるんだったら
自分の権力は危うく状態になったなとか思ってもいいんだけど
[背景音楽]それは独裁者の感情じゃないんですかね
まあそういうのはまあただあの別な説明私は持ってますけど
あまり言いたくはないんです
これってのはちょっと理解範囲は
まあ理解できないものを言うと
みんなああそうですかとよく分かったような気持ちになるんですけどね
あまり言いたくはないんです
うん まあ一応そんな程度で理解したらいいんじゃない？別にまああんまりいてもいなくてもどうせ仏教に関係ないことだからね
仏教から見れば自分の心もマーラであって
周り関係は全てマーラであって
それに戦わなくちゃいけないんでしょうしね
応援してくれる人っていないんです
だから仏法僧のみを味方だよと生命のね
だからサンキューするんですよ
唯一の味方なんです 他はみんな味方じゃないんです
足を引っ張るだけ はい
えーと 話が私の語彙はちょっと初心者なんでなんですけども
慈悲の瞑想なんかの今唱える時に
あの この歌うようにとか
まあ調子があるみたいなんですけど
こう 声の音の音って言うんですか
その部分でどのようなことを気つけて唱えればいいんでしょうか
調子というか なんかちょっとこう
まあそんなのは気にしないでください
自分好きなようにやればいいんです
これは一人でやる時は自分好きなようにやればよろしいんです
みんなでやる場合はそれなりに合わせるということなんですけど
それ言ったらみんな逆やってますからね
まあそれはもう だから私はやらないことにしたんです
一人でやる時は自分のやり方
やりたい放題でやり方やってもよろしいし
みんなでやる場合はいい加減みんなにも同じくまとめなさいって言ってるでしょう
そうするとみんなでやると俺の声出してやるぞということで
全て調子を崩し壊しちゃうんです
一人でやってる場合は一生懸命真似してやるぞっていうね
まあどうぞ頑張ってください
もうもう諦めた私 まあ一応答えはね
まあ自分一人でやる場合は自分好きな調子でよろしいんですよ
あの なんかナモラッサとかこう
音とかそういうものを考えて作られた韻とかなんか踏んだのか
なんかこう  まあそんなにね
まあ一応人間っていうのは音によって振動だから
脳がその振動を受けて
すごくまあ音っていうのは直接脳に行く振動でしょ
だから精神的に落ち着く
あの幸福感感じるっていうね
我々いう幸福っていうのは脳のからくりだからね
我々いう楽しみっていうのはただの脳のからくりでしょ
だからそこで脳に穏やかな振動を与えると
脳が快楽感 喜悦感 幸福感
落ち着く穏やかさというのを感じるんですよ
まあそんな程度なんですよ
だから私なんかもせっかちだから
こう早くこう私が幸福で幸せでありますようにとか
早口でこう言っているんじゃなくて
やはりこのリズムって
ここで聴いてるこのリズムはすごくなんかすごく穏やかな気持ちになれるっていう印象を受けたんですけども
割とそれが多少こう その自分のペースに持っていってくれないっていう
そうですね  ありがとうございます
すいません 先ほど二面性ということで
本当の自分 自分と見せている自分っていう話があったんですけども
そういうふうに考えて本当の自分は醜いっていう風に考えるのもある時は大事だと思うんですけども
あの 私の思うには その
今自分が醜い欲求を出してるとかっていうことがあれば
それを今自分は醜いという風に見るようにすればいいのかなと思ったんですよね
よくよくじゃなくて すいません
間違えました あの 以前
以前ですね 知り合いから本当の自分って何だろうって
あの悩みを相談されたことがあったんですけども
その時にまあ私思ったのは
本当の自分っていうのはなくて
その時その時その自分が出てるだけで
まあそんなもの 本当の自分を探そうとしなくてもいいっていうようなことを言ったことがあるんですけども
まあそういうふうに その
今自分がどういう心の状態かを見てくっていうのは大事かなと思ったんですね
ただそれをちょっと言い換えると
あんまり醜いものを見たくないっていう心が働いていて
そこに目を向けようとしてない自分もいるんだという気はするんですけども
でもあんまりそういう風に考えてるとすごい重くなってくるんで
今感じたことをそのままストレートに思えばいいのかなと最近は思ってるんですけど
うん ちょっと逃げがあるんですけど
知らん私は [笑い]別に質問ということじゃなくて
ただ感想ですね うん あの自分はこんなものだと固定して見ること自体も間違いなんですよ
本当の自分は今言ったんだから
暗くて醜くてとか言ったでしょうに
固定しているような見るという
それまた固定概念ですよ
そこを何とかしようと思っても
そうはいかないんですね
だからそのその状況に演技で反応する自分を観察していけば
まあなんとかなるってことなんです
大体私はこういうものだと言える人よりは
私は何者か自分でもわかりませんよという人の方が
もしかするとマシかもしれません
そんなはっきりしたこと言えませんよ
即席のことだからね 花は綺麗ですか？あるいは汚いですかと聞きませんでしょ
そのその立場でいるだけの話でね
ご飯は美味しいですかとかね
やっぱりその時空間系で
そのある時は美味しいし
ある時は美味しくはないしね
だから世の中のことっていうのは
自分のことも世の中のことでしょうにね
その都度その都度何かを演じる
だからその時その時のあれだというのも正しいし
それでずっと演じてると
なんでこの一貫して何を演じているのかと見ると
それはいくらか自分というものになってくるんですね
そんなもんで だからといって自分という固定したものがあるわけでもないんです
例えば演じる場合はずっと何か守ってるでしょ
何かを守るために演じているんですね
怒っても心の中は怒っているのにニコッと笑っているとか
演じでしょ あれ なんで演じているのか
何か守ってるんでしょ
嫌な人なのにすごい丁寧に挨拶したりする
それもまた演じでしょ
[笑い]子供たちでも好きな人がいるんだけど
ちっちゃな子供たちはあえていじめたりする
それも演技でしょうにね
小学生の子供たちとかね
恋する時もあるでしょうに
で 好きな人がいるんだけど
両方もう女の子も男も同じなんです
その時はもう何か気に入ったら結局そいつをいじめるんですよ
あの年で女の子たちも好きな男があの子は好きだなと本人好きだとわからないんですね
それが気に入っている
いて蹴ったり いろんないじめをしたりする
それで子供っていうのはいじめられるの嫌だからね
まだお母さんにもすごい大事にしている年だから
嫌で嫌で訳がないとかね
で 何もなく素直に仲良くしましょう
友達になろうよと言ったら
そうすると友達になれるのに
で 何か演じちゃうんですね
だからこの演じる世界で私は何かを
私たちは何かを守っている
自分というものをね 見せないようにしようとするね
だからそれわかる そんなのは何もないんだからいい加減にしろという仏教なんですよ
楽なんですね 何を守るんだ
何もないんだと だから自我があると大変ですよ
これ守らなくちゃいかんだから
我々はあると思ってるんですけどね
これないという事実発見しちゃうと
ああ なんだこうということで
すっごくもう言葉を超えた状態で楽になる
そういう人はだから怒った時は勝手に怒ると
それはありえなくなっちゃうんですね
怒ったのは自我を守るために
欲出したのも自我を守るために
ないと思ったら 自動的に欲も怒りも何もないんだから
もうすごい戒律完成した人になっているんです
そういうことですよね
おそらくまあ それも私の感想で終わります
はい  正しく知るということなんですが
自分の体と心につきましては
戒律を守って瞬間瞬間に気づきを入れて
正しく知るというのが目標になると思うのですが
それがそれとは別に社会制度とかですね
間接的に知るもの 例えば日本の国
小泉さんの政策とかですね
そのものを日にこう我々情報を受けているのですが
それを正しく知るというデータの捉え方ですね
あの 長老が言われていましたが
どういう点に気をつけてデータを見るのが正しい見方なのかについていただければ
それで正しくする必要ないでしょう
世の中のデータは 能力なかったらする必要ないんですよ
余計なことでね どうせ向こうはデータを正しく言わないでしょ？小泉さんであろうが
ブッシュさんであろうが
もう世界経済 世界経済世界であろうが
誰一人も事実は言ってくれないでしょう
たとえ裁判というのは真理を調べるところでしょ
誰が事実語ってますかね
裁判さえでも嘘ばっかりでしょ
だからなんでそんなそんなのはどうでもいいっていうことですよ
まあ自分に関係あるところで適当に適切に極端に走らないで生きることしかできないんです
しかし 今の瞬間瞬間 自分を観察していくと
自分というもののからくり見えてきますよ
自分が人と喋る場合は
どのようにデータを捏造するのかとかね
どのようにそこを作品作って発表するのかというね
自分のからくりが見えてくる
そこをはっきり分かったら
みんな人間だから違うことをやるはずがないんです
その方式公式当てはめてみると見えてくるんです
自分が分かれば  うん うん
すぐ単純です はい  先ほど唯一の見方のフットワークに参拝するっておっしゃいましたけど
参拝するときに何か自分の中で言葉を
参拝すると私は言ってない
言ってないんで 私は賛敬と言ったんです
じゃあ賛敬の言葉をお辞儀をするときに何か自分の中で言葉を一緒に思いながらした方がいいのか
そういう時にする もし言葉があるならどんな
そういうところはご自分で考えてやってください
自分だけのバージョンでいいんです
誰にも言わないっていう
うん 賛敬っていうのは
やっぱりそれを賛敬するということも
言葉では賛敬になりません
それは勉強してください
賛敬っていうのは 仏法僧は自分の指導者として
案内するガイドとして
先生として認めることなんです
仏法僧が私の人生の先生だよと
ただ口先だけで言ったってもね
先生にしておかないとダメでしょ
だからちゃんと賛敬した人がどんな判断をする時でも
どんなことをする時でも
基準は仏法僧にするんですね
だからそれが 1 日でできるものじゃないんですよ
今日からブッダ言う通りにやるぞとね
思ったってもね だから
まあ敬っていうのは自動的についてきます
ちゃんと理解して納得していくと
まず仏教の教えは真理として納得しなくちゃいけないんですね
納得するまで頑張らないと
納得いったらもう敬になっています
で じゃあそんなに真理ですから
私はこれからその通りに生きていなくちゃいけないんではないかと自分で決めたところで敬なんです
こんな人の話を聞いたってもね
みんな味方じゃないんだよと
というふうなところに達したら
これ敬のお礼なんです
まあ普通参拝する時は自分なりに自分なりの言葉でよろしいんです
じゃあやめましょう  では
ダマーパラー講義を終わりたいと思います
皆さんで参拝して終わりたいと思います
参拝